cocomme tant d'autres,
sasans indication aucune.
MaMais elle mène vers un autre
momonde. Un voyage au centre
dede la Terre. Nous sommes
dadans les catacombes d'Odessa.
UnUn réseau de tunnels souterras
crcreusés au fil du temps
papar des génératitions de mines
ququi y ont laissé leur trace.
I Igor Grek n'est jamais aussi
heheureux que lorsqu'il
esest sous terre.
I Il n'était qu'un adolescentnt
ququand il y est descendu
popour la première fois.
C'C'était il y a 42 ans.
UnUn coup de foudre.
" "J'étais curieux de découvrir
cece qui se trouve au-delà
dudu prochain virage, dit-il.
EtEt c'est encore
lele cas aujourd'hui."
U Une passion devenue professi.
IlIl est aujourd'hui l'un
dedes spéléologues les plus
enen vue en Ukraine.
I Igor connaît le réseau
dedes catacombes comme le fond
dede sa poche. Ses origines,
seses multiples usages
auau fil du temps.
S Situés à plus de 20 mètres
sosous la surface, les souterras
cocontiennent plusieurs bunkers
coconstruits au milieu du siècle
dedernier pour se protéger
dedes bombardements.
A Alors Igor sait où aller
enen cas d'attaque venue du cie.
" "Les habitants de la ville
pepeuvent s'installer ici
àà l'abri des bombes, dit-il.
OnOn peut y rester longtemps
enen toute sécurité."
C C'est la raison qui a poussé
Aleksandr Sadovnikovov à aménagr
leles cacatacombes près de
chchez lui en abri antiaérien.
D Dès les premiers jours
dede la guerre, il y a installé
totout le nécessaire à la survie
dedes gens du quartier.
" "On a mis des matelas ici
popour s'asseoir, dit-il.
IlIl y a des casques et là,
unun peu d'eau potable."
I Il a pensé à tout.
I Il l a pensé à tout.
DeDes chambres, des toilettes,
dede la lumière et même interne.
EtEt puis tout près de l'entrée,
unune grande salle à manger.
" "Les gens du quartier
dedescendent ici lorsque sonnent
leles sirènes d'alerte", dit-il.
U Un abri très populaire,
seselon Aleksandr. Il a accueili
rérécemment près de 300 personns
enen même temps.
I Il n'existe pas de cartogrape
ofofficielle des catacombes
d'd'Odessa, mais la légende
veveut que le réseau soit long
dede plusieurs milliers
dede kilomètres. Quoi qu'il
enen soit, une chose est clairi,
enen cas de besoin, une bonne
papartie de la population pourrt
sese réfugier ici et y rester
trtrès longtemps.
I Ici Jean-François Bélanger,
R Radio-Canada, Odess